Secret swords, initials carved in the background,
and celebrity cameos so small you didn't even
notice. These are just a few of the Easter
Eggs you missed while watching Game of Thrones.
In the books, the Iron Throne is a monstrosity,
sitting over 20 feet tall and made from the
blades of thousands of opponents vanquished by
Aegon Targaryen. Obviously, a throne that size
wouldn't be easy to film for television, so
the famous prop used in the Red Keep set is
much smaller than the one described in the books.
The showrunners knew this might cause complaints
among fans of the novels, so they threw in
this fun little bit of meta-dialogue in the
Season 3 episode "The Climb" between Varys
and Littlefinger. Varys solemnly mentions
the legend of the the thousand blades, and
Littlefinger has a pretty cheeky response:
"There aren't a thousand blades. There
aren't even two hundred. I've counted."
Speaking of the Iron Throne, did you know that
some of those vanquished foes apparently include
Ian McKellen and Orlando Bloom? That's
right — eagle-eyed viewers have spotted
a few "famous" swords hidden among
the generic blades in the Iron Throne.
Notably, you can see Glamdring, wielded by
Gandalf in the Lord of the Rings movies.
There are also swords from both Kingdom of
Heaven and Robin Hood: Prince of Thieves.
Following Ned Stark's execution at the hands
of King Joffrey, the new monarch shows us
more of his sadistic streak when he forces Sansa
Stark to come and look at her father's head
displayed on a pike above the
Red Keep. Along with Ned's head,
several other members of the Stark household and
guard in King's Landing are also stuck on spikes
nearby. Apparently, one time U.S. President
George W. Bush was part of the Stark retinue,
because his head was impaled on a
pike right next to Sansa's old septa.
The showrunners explained that the use of
President Bush's head wasn't intentional but
rather a budget issue of just using whatever
prop heads were available at the time.
Nonetheless, some viewers took issue with the
scene, which prompted HBO to issue an apology
and digitally edit the face on the head to make
it less recognizable in future DVD releases.
George R. R. Martin is a known fan of the British
comedy troupe Monty Python — particularly their
movie, Monty Python and the Holy Grail. References
to the film are sprinkled throughout the books,
and the showrunners made sure to include some in
the television series as well. In the Season 4
episode "Breaker of Chains," Daenerys arrives at
the city of Meereen with her army of Unsullied.
The Meereenese send out a champion, who hurls
several insults at the Dragon Queen before
Daario beheads the poor fool. According to
show linguist David Peterson, the beginning of
his speech translates as a direct quote from the
French Taunter in Monty Python and the Holy Grail.
"Your mother was a hamster, and
your father smelt of elderberries."
Long before the Tower of Joy scene in the Season
6 finale finally confirmed the long-held fan
theory that Jon Snow is the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna Stark, Game of Thrones
made a sneaky reference to the theory with a
set piece. In the Season 1 episode "Cripples,
Bastards, and Broken Things," Jon Snow
and Samwell Tarly are scrubbing a table
and joking around about their past experiences
with women. Additionally, Jon reveals that he
doesn't know who his mother was. If you watch
closely during a scene from the same episode,
you can see the letters "R" and "L" carved
into the post that Jon is standing next to,
which seems to tease us by
confirming the idea that R+L = J.
On several occasions, famous bands or musicians
found their way into Game of Thrones in cameo
roles. Coldplay drummer Will Champion played a
percussionist in the group of Frey musicians at
the Red Wedding, whilst Sigur Ros made an
appearance as another set of minstrels at
Joffrey and Margaery's Purple Wedding. Gary
Lightbody, the singer from Snow Patrol,
made a cameo as a singer with Vargo Hoat's "Brave
Companions" in Season 3. Finally, the rockers of
Mastodon got an enviable and totally metal scene
as wildlings at Hardhome who get brutally killed
before rising again as the wight thralls of the
White Walkers. Additionally, singer-songwriter Ed
Sheeran made waves with a controversial cameo
in the first episode of the seventh season,
playing a friendly Lannister soldier named
Eddie whom Arya encounters on the Kingsroad.
Musician Ed Sheeran's Season 7 cameo as the
Lannister soldier Eddie was poorly received.
Many viewers thought Sheeran's
presence felt shoehorned in,
and ultimately crippled the show's sense
of reality, resulting in a multitude of
scathing reactions and comments. In
response, Sheeran even told Buzzfeed,
"I definitely think they should've
killed me off in the episode. I
reckon that probably would've been the
redemption for people that didn't like it."
The good news for fans, critics, and Sheeran is
that their collective wish came at least partially
true in the form of a subtle reference during the
Season 8 premiere. The Easter egg comes during the
scene in which Ser Bronn is in bed with three
courtesans. While they disrobe, the three women
recount some of their favorite Lannister men who
either never came home from war or, in Eddie's
case, came home horribly disfigured. They refer
to Eddie by name, even calling him "the ginger."
"Came back with his face burnt
right off. He's got no eyelids now."
Remember that time when Littlefinger gave
away the rest of the season's major deaths
in a single sentence? In the Season 4
episode "The Mountain and the Viper,"
Littlefinger gives some sage advice to
Robin Arryn at the Eyrie, telling him,
"People die at their dinner
tables. They die in their beds.
They die squatting over their chamber pots."
The first part is clearly a reference to
King Joffrey, who was already dead at this
point. But the latter two refer to events that
Littlefinger could have no foreknowledge of
unless he's psychic. Later that season, Tyrion
would kill his former lover Shae in a bed,
and his father Tywin while he was squatting over
his chamber pot. Thanks for the spoilers, Baelish.
When the young Ned Stark enters the Tower of Joy
after defeating Arthur Dayne, he leans Dayne's
sword up against the foot of Lyanna's bed as
he approaches her. For book fans who were eager
to see a glimpse of the fabled sword Dawn, the
camera lingers for a moment on the bloody sword.
Beyond this visual Easter egg, for some Game of
Thrones theorists, the presence of the sword at
Jon's birth confirms the theory that Jon Snow is
actually Azor Ahai — the Prince that was Promised,
"Born amidst salt and smoke,
beneath a bleeding star."
As readers will be quick to inform you, the
Dayne ancestral sword of Dawn was supposedly
forged from the heart of a star, and the sword is
most definitely covered in blood. Is it a stretch?
Possibly. But what else did fans have to speculate
about once Jon's parentage was finally made clear?
For horrified fans of House Stark who watched the
downfall of Robb and Catelyn at the Red Wedding,
revenge couldn't come soon enough. It took several
seasons, but the payback was truly worth the wait.
During the Red Wedding, Robb Stark’s wife
is stabbed in the belly by Lothar Frey,
Robb is stabbed in the heart by Roose Bolton,
Catelyn has her throat slit by Walder Rivers,
and Robb’s dire wolf Grey Wind is killed
with crossbows. The deaths of the Red Wedding
conspirators match those of their victims
— Tywin Lannister is shot with a crossbow,
Roose Bolton is stabbed in the gut,
and Walder Frey's throat is slit by
Arya Stark. For the Stark family,
justice is both poetic and sweet.
While staying at the Nightfort along
the Wall with Jojen, Meera, and Hodor,
Bran relates the ancient tale of the Rat Cook,
as told to him by Old Nan. Hundreds of years ago,
an Andal king was visiting the Nightfort with his
son. A cook at the Night's Watch castle was angry
with the king for some supposed wrong and murdered
the prince and baked him into a pie with bacon,
which he then served to the king. The king was so
pleased with the pie that he asked for a second
piece. According to the legend, the old gods were
so outraged by this that they cursed the cook,
turning him into a giant white rat
that can only survive by eating his
own young. Supposedly the rat still roams
the Nightfort today. According to Bran,
"It was not for murder that
the gods cursed the Rat Cook,
nor for serving the king's son in a pie."
The tale is still told in Westeros as a warning
as to what happens to those who break guests'
rights — like Walder Frey. His eventual
death echoes many aspects of the story.
Before killing him, Arya Stark kills two
of his sons and cooks them into a pie,
which she then serves to Walder Frey. It isn't
obvious in the scene, but if you look closely, you
can see that Walder already has the scraps of one
piece of pie on his plate, and the piece that Arya
brings him is his second. Revenge is truly a dish
best served cold — and full of dismembered toes.
"He killed a guest beneath his roof, and
that's something the gods can't forgive."
During Season 7, a mountain that "looks like
an arrowhead" became a pivotal landmark when
Jon and his band of merry men went beyond the
Wall in search of a wight to capture. Seen by
Sandor Clegane during a vision, the mountain is
used by the group to guide them on their journey.
It wasn't the first time we'd
seen the mountain on the show,
however — it also loomed in the
background of Bran's Season 6 vision,
when he watched the Children of the Forest create
the first White Walker. At that point in time,
the area surrounding the peak was lush and green,
not the frozen tundra it is now. In reality, this
mountain is a popular landmark in Iceland, where
a large portion of Game of Thrones is filmed.
Although the Boltons are now dead and gone,
the damage they did to the Stark family
goes much deeper than psychological trauma.
We got a glimpse of that trauma in the
second episode of Season 7, when Jon leaves
the Winterfell crypt after a tense conversation
with Littlefinger. If you were paying attention,
you may have noticed the headless statues
standing guard outside the crypt's entrance.
What's the significance of these
broken guardians? As seen in Season 1,
two sturdy and detailed dire wolf statues
stood on either side of the crypt entrance.
Theon Greyjoy may have held Winterfell
with his Ironborn for a brief time,
but it wasn't until the Boltons took up residence
that these statues were desecrated. The Boltons
were trying to replace the Starks as the new
power in the North, and by beheading the statues,
they were reminding the people of Winterfell who
was in charge. In addition, these beheaded statues
underscore for the viewer what has been lost;
the remaining Stark siblings have been reunited,
but so many others have died. In fact, two
of those deaths — Robb's and Rickon's — came
directly at the hands of the Boltons,
making this an even more poignant reminder.
During the course of Season 7, a certain
Valyrian steel knife known as the "Catspaw
dagger" came into play on multiple occasions.
First, Littlefinger gave the knife to Bran, who
then passed it on to Arya. As Sansa explained in
the season finale, Littlefinger told Catelyn that
the dagger had belonged to Tyrion Lannister–which
caused Catelyn to kidnap Tyrion, Tywin Lannister
to go to war, and Jaime Lannister to attack
Ned Stark in the streets of King's Landing.
In reality, it was Littlefinger's dagger, and
his lies had been designed to create chaos.
But the story of this particular
dagger actually goes back much further.
When Samwell Tarly is researching Dragonglass
in Oldtown, he flips through the pages of a
book about the topic. Actor John Bradley told
the Huffington Post that during the scene,
he was directed to "linger on this page" so
audiences could get a good look, signifying
that the reference is an important one. On one
page is an illustration of the Catspaw dagger,
with text indicating that it's made of Valyrian
steel with Dragonglass ornamentation — meaning,
it's made of the two materials that can kill
White Walkers. Another clue hidden on that
page suggests that the Catspaw dagger may once
have belonged to Aegon the Conqueror himself.
When Bran received the dagger from Littlefinger,
he asked him an important question.
"Do you know who this belonged to?"
This question has much more meaning now that
we know it may have been Aegon the First's,
and that Jon's true name is also Aegon
Targaryen. And the dagger's long,
bloody history may yet continue, as
the weapon seems to make an appearance
in a trailer for House of the Dragon,
wielded by a member of House Hightower.
In the Season 7 episode "Beyond the Wall,"
Daenerys is forced to rescue Jon and his
crew when their mission to trap a wight ends
with them in the middle of a frozen lake,
surrounded by the army of the dead.
Unfortunately, Jon gets pulled into
the icy waters before Dany can save him.
Luckily, he emerges mostly unscathed,
and his Uncle Benjen unexpectedly shows up —
giving Jon his horse and sacrificing himself
to the horde of wights to give his nephew a
head start. When Jon arrives back at Eastwatch,
he's hypothermic and is quickly brought aboard
their ship, where Daenerys watches in horror as
she sees Jon's old scars from when he was
murdered by the Night's Watch mutineers.
This Easter egg is all about those
scars — or rather, their placement.
Daenerys' lost love Khal Drogo had a scar
through his left eyebrow, as does Jon.
Additionally, Drogo died from an
infected wound very near his heart,
and Jon has a puckered scar in the same place.
The similarities between these scars may have
contributed to Daenerys' shock when she saw Jon's
wounds.It likely brought up horrible memories of
how her first husband died. Would she lose Jon the
same way? It's clear from the following scene that
she'd been sitting at Jon's bedside for hours,
just as she did for Drogo when he was near death,
hoping against hope that he'd return
to her. This time, she got her wish.
Fans rejoiced when Ser Davos Seaworth tracked
down Gendry in the Season 7 episode "Eastwatch,"
and found out that he hadn't actually been
rowing for the last four seasons. Instead,
Gendry was working for himself in the
Street of Steel at King's Landing.
When Davos asks Gendry to come back to
Dragonstone, Gendry jumps at the chance — only
pausing to grab an exquisitely crafted war
hammer. Gendry is pretty darn good with it,
too, as seen when he smashes in
the heads of two nosy Gold Cloaks.
Gendry's war hammer was embellished with
a golden stag, which is the sigil of House
Baratheon. When Robert was in his prime, he
was known for his prowess with a war hammer,
which he used to kill Rhaegar Targaryen. It's
likely that Gendry knows this, which may be
why he made himself the weapon — a reference to
his father's favored hammer. What's really fun
about all of this is the initial meeting between
Gendry and Jon, when Gendry tells Jon something.
"Our fathers trusted each
other; why shouldn't we?"
Gendry was referring to Robert and Ned, but we
know Jon's real father was Rhaegar Targaryen,
and Gendry's father actually killed Jon's.
A fun fact about Game of Thrones that may
have eluded even the hardcore fans is that
the franchise's world has no official name. In
fact, characters in both the books and TV series
simply refer to the planet as "the world" or
"the known world," with no alternative proposed.
That's because George R.R. Martin
always intended the books to focus
almost exclusively on one of the world's
continents. That continent is Westeros,
and aside from brief forays into the far
western shore of Essos, Westeros is home to
all of the events of the series. And, as one
observant fan noticed, that home bears an
uncanny resemblance to the islands of Ireland
and Great Britain stacked on top of another.
Martin himself has always been
outspoken about his desire to base
his setting on the British Isles, even
describing the known world like this:
"A super-Europe-super-Asia
and a giant British Isles,
and, you know, like they would have
actually known in the Middle Ages."
He was, of course, referring to Essos
and Westeros respectively. But to see
Westeros so neatly aligned with the two largest
British Isles is still a striking reference.
One way Game of Thrones sets itself apart
from other fantasy franchises is keeping
its mythological creatures comparatively limited
in number. There are only a handful of different
fantasy beasts that appear throughout the series,
and the very first non-human characters to
appear — the Stark children's iconic dire
wolves — aren't actually mythical at all.
Dire wolves were a real species that interacted
with humans and went extinct only recently.
That fact helps lend a primal, visceral depth to
the way the Game of Thrones wolves connect with
the Starks. It's a joyous moment when Arya and
her wolf Nymeria finally reconnect in Season 7,
although the pair almost immediately part
ways for reasons that might confuse viewers
whose memories of Season 1 are a little
fuzzy. Arya says something odd to Nymeria.
"That's not you."
From this, fans could've gotten the idea
that this interaction is a simple case
of mistaken identity. In fact, it's a
subtle Easter egg years in the making.
Arya isn't claiming to have
confused the wolf for her own,
but rather calling back to a line of dialogue from
Season 1, when she said this to her father Ned.
"That's not me."
This was in response to him trying to sell her
on the traditionally feminine life of a princess.
Just as Arya knew that her path wasn't going
to be decided by others, she knew that Nymeria
was going to choose her own path as well — even
if it meant creating a new family without her.
It's no secret that George R. R.
Martin loves J. R. R. Tolkien's work,
with the Game of Thrones author even claiming that
"I yield to no one in my admiration
for 'Lord of the Rings.'"
Even when Martin finds himself in competition with
Tolkien's franchise, such as in the simultaneously
airing seasons of House of the Dragon and
Rings of Power, he can't help but hope that
the Tolkien-inspired show succeeds, even while
hoping House of the Dragon succeeds slightly more.
That's why many fans have been quick to
notice certain parallels between Martin's
characters and Tolkien's, especially their
two main protagonists: Jon Snow and Frodo.
Both are orphans raised by surrogate
fathers. Both have best friends named
Sam and another bestie whose name is Pip,
possibly spelled with a "y". Both enter
the realm of death after being stabbed
only to return via magical intervention.
Both still feel the mortal wounds they endured
years later. Both save the world from what is
ultimately its greatest evil. Both are unable
to find peace or happiness in their newly-saved
world. And both eventually leave their normal
world to start new lives in a realm of even more
fantasy. In the latter case, that's the Undying
Lands for Frodo and Beyond the Wall for Snow.
Anyone who finds themselves in charge of one
of the biggest and most beloved fantasy series
of all time must feel constant temptation to
cast themselves in the show. After spending the
majority of their waking moments for years
imagining and creating a fictional world,
those with the ability to put themselves inside
must seriously consider it. For Game of Thrones
showrunners David Benioff and D.B. Weiss,
the temptation was simply too much to resist.
Their first cameo comes when Arya visits the
Hall of Faces. Molds of both showrunners' faces
appear among the many that fill that
ghastly room. As Weiss once revealed,
"Both David and myself appeared many,
many times in the Hall of Faces...
there is at least 20 or 30 of me in there."
We've covered a huge number of cameos already, but
one important cameo remains thus far unmentioned:
Rob McElhenney, the creator, writer, and
co-star of It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia.
Though he's best known for playing
Mac on the brilliant FX comedy,
McElhenney also landed a role on Game
of Thrones in the Season 8 premiere.
During Theon's mission to rescue Yara, her
loyalists launch a quick, silent assault on
the Ironborn ship in which she's held captive. The
opening moments of the attack see five Ironborn
sailors struck by arrows before they can even
react. The first of these sailors is none other
than McElhenney, who receives enough of a closeup
to confirm his role. However, like so many in Game
of Thrones, McElhenney's character — known only
as "Ironborn 1" — was always fated to die. The
arrow that strikes him sails through his head and
out his eye, killing him brutally and instantly.
If you haven't seen Disney's 1981 live-action
fantasy film Dragonslayer, do yourself a favor
and watch it immediately. It's well reviewed,
a cult favorite, and an inspiration to
many industry professionals. In particular,
the film's dragon — Vermithrax Pejorative — has
left an indelible mark on some major names.
Guillermo del Toro, for one, called the dragon
"[...] one of the most perfect
creature designs ever made."
Another fantasy big-shot who forever has eyes
for Vermithrax is the author of Thrones himself,
George R. R. Martin, who called the creature
"[...] the best dragon ever put on film,
and has the coolest dragon name as well."
D.B. Weiss also shares Martin's love for
the wonderfully realistic dragon, which is
why he snuck in an Easter egg to reference it in
Season 1. While Viserys is bathing with a woman,
he tells her about his childhood walking among
the skulls of dragons past in the Red Keep.
Among the names of long-dead dragons
comes — you guessed it — Vermithrax.
On the episode's Blu-ray commentary, writer Bryan
Cogman confirmed that the homage was Weiss's idea,
an intentional nod to "one of
the great '80s fantasy films."
No part of Game of Thrones exists without adding
to the show's constant storytelling and world
building. So even the characters' outfits
were designed to convey specific reactions,
emotions, and character traits. Speaking with
Elle, costume designer Michele Clapton revealed
a few of her more noticeable contributions to
the final seasons' characters and tone. She said,
"Winter has come [...] People say 'Where's the
color gone?' If the end of the world was coming as
you know it, you wouldn't actually be colorful and
bright. You'd start being incredibly practical."
That shows in many of the female characters'
clothes, which gradually shifted from bright
colors and flowing fabrics to blacks and
grays wrapped tightly around the body.
Clapton also revealed many
Easter eggs in Sansa's outfits
and the subtle references they make to
the character's greatest influences,
including her mother and father. They
even hint at the influences Sansa took
from Cersei and Littlefinger. The outfits also
reflect Sansa's traumas or, as Clapton put it,
"I wanted it to look as if she was actually
sewn or laced into her dress — like there was
no way in. She's trying to protect herself
from all the awfulness that's happened."
Of course, this is all even more
impressive when you consider the
fact that some of the wardrobe is just IKEA rugs.
There are many facets of Game of
Thrones, from its myriad characters,
intricately interwoven storylines, and
expansive scope of in-universe history.
But, the series' single greatest source of
Easter eggs comes from one surprising place:
its opening animation sequence. The sequence,
widely hailed as one of the most epic of all time
and an Emmy winner itself, travels across
the map of the known world and changes from
episode to episode, adding more Easter
eggs for eagle-eyed fans to unearth.
The sequence's many variations share one
of the most elaborate pages on the Game of
Thrones wiki page, and with good reason — they
not only chronicle the history of the series,
but they also tease its future. As Kirk Shintani,
part of the team at Elastic that
created the sequence, told The Wrap,
"As the episodes progress, you know, as the
set piece changes, the things that you notice
happen later, you might find little hints of
those same things in the previous episodes."
As a specific example, he cited the
revamped Season 8 sequence, saying:
"Everything that is going to be there
for all six episodes. Those elements
will have been in the Season 8 opening
credits from the premiere episode."